did you inflate the price because they
could became properly tell the truth
yeah we'll live that all the [ __ ]
what's up world this is your puppy
partner checking in to change what you
got going on here I got some of the best
bulldogs on the planet right here no
[ __ ] no [ __ ] they're perfect for
the house so they're very popular in the
last five or ten years bulldogs because
they're smaller people like keeping the
apartments and houses very very popular
very popular with celebrities he's about
10 grand this one's going right here to
Thailand sold for 10,000 and this one
we're keeping right here just well the
highest quality Bulldogs we produced in
the last 15 years what you get right
here who's this little fella right here
this guy right here is a micro machine
he's know right now is one of the best
blue French bulldogs on the planet it's
got some orange eyes which is really
exotic on the dog his structure is
really the best you can get small
compact he's 20 pounds what yeah he's
about three years right now
yeah do you breathe he's sorry about 35
litters last year over half million
dollars in puppies his puppies sell for
five to ten thousand a piece and and we
got him worldwide right now I want one
this is the biggest [ __ ] known about
this and you've made it happen glad
she's doing better mostly strapless
these samples see me we'll get off on
this time I drop a seaman is five
thousand yeah I need to step my game I
like you know man me and you man we can
go and I can travel the only 20 pound
three years ago so he potty training
everything everything's good to go yeah
I love you man got to worry about
cleaning up this [ __ ] can you send me in
he's actually my mom's ask her but he
likes me to know I have to talk to my
mom
yeah so how much is this guy he would be
about 25 two hundred thousand just
because of how much he commits he's
either number one in the world you know
his puppy could be about 10 grand you
know because we don't know the puppy if
it's gonna turn out like him or not
[ __ ] ground I'll try to move it hey
100,000 for you bro our team hundred
thousand [ __ ] you got to be
driving me somewhere are they protective
do they do they know the real nice dogs
oh yeah keep you really do you wanna
protect you no no I still own the bark
of a car pull in the driveway
oh yeah you will for sure yeah yeah all
right so listen you have a dog that they
cost more than this dog yes
and the famous bucket damn panda bear
Eddie okay that's the English this is
English
this is number one blue English Bulldog
in the world he's about 70 pounds
he pays like eat way his fat ass yeah
he's a big boy Oh like why is he so big
is that healthy boy
it's it it's part of the breed that's
part of the things people go for is more
roles more girth more size on them come
on have a seat sit down boy c8 put it
down a micro micro Mike Ross put it down
somewhere oh sit down somewhere
110 Michael I got one more to show you
guys and that's me this puppy right here
father go boy's father which is PUD oh
say I like to see micro micro come on
baby Michael
not know this camera funny in the face
did Josh see this in the face look at
his dog yes you know why somebody's JB
basketball coach probably one of the top
ones in the nation as far as overdone
Bulldogs look very that was so cute that
was Brad in his puppies for $10,000
$10,000 for thought now I do on three
dollars on two pit bulls gonna own a
chihuahua I know you laughing for my
chihuahua or flush your ass so I really
like the dogs and I like the whole
culture around dogs I was raised around
dogs when they start being $10,000 they
better know how to bathe themselves feed
themselves
these dogs better not ever die that's
what better happened